there's nothing like the gathering of
raider fans raider nation shows up from
all corners of the country and if not
for kovit fans will be flying in from
mexico and europe in large numbers it's
still a carnival only now the black hole
will be vega sized
other teams have tried but there is
nothing like the black hole it's more
than a fan base much more family
you know
like nina raider fan it's family it's
fun it's a good time this is the epitome
of raider nation
we are
the best franchise in sports this silver
and black family live and breathe for
their team it's a nation of fans with a
reputation some carry that enthusiasm on
their sleeve for others it's a
livelihood we'll be out there in vegas
who knows that the black hole will grow
in the vegas desert but with that iconic
brand chapters of the black hole dot the
countryside
hardcore
i know i love it i love all the
characters
i think it's great
we've been doing this a long long time
all right i agree with that lady i love
the black hole and all the carnival
atmosphere i